i want to jump to this story here
and it's brutal
man arrested after beheading young
mother in the middle of san carlos
street law enforcement sources
now they they may have had a domestic
issue the guy attacks her and then uses
a sword to remove her head in in view
the public and there's two things i
noticed from this
you know there's a story uh i think it
was a few months ago maybe a year ago
about a woman who was on a subway train
when a man raped her it was in philly
and everybody watched and they filmed it
and just let it happen and i thought to
myself like how does that happen that
people just stand there and watch that
like watch someone do that
same thing here now i get it with this
story dude as a sword right okay guys
got a sword
what can you really do shoot him but yes
that was the correct answer
not in california
not in california where they
criminalized self-defense is that what
that happened was in cali yeah so here's
here's my point right we're segueing off
of this you know what's happening with
this revolution and you made a really
good point before the show dave you said
that they're decriminalizing like
they're letting people go with all this
violent crime and then they're
criminalizing self-defense right that is
an untenable situation for any
civilization and the only result can be
collapsed well you know something really
interesting about like the kind of rise
of the progressive prosecutors who i you
know from my perspective a a lot of
times as they were uh running in some
places where they need to get elected or
as they were like campaigning for the
job they they made points that i thought
were somewhat reasonable when they were
talking about you know things like bail
reform
where you look you you certainly can
make the argument that it's a pretty
messed up system
that if you have money
you get out of jail and if you don't
have the money you have to stay in jail
until trial there's there's an ar
there's a really reasonable argument to
have there there's certainly a
reasonable argument that over the last
40 years in america we have been way too
harsh on crimes like uh like drug
possession even drug distribution on
crimes like gun possession you know
these things it's it's outrageous the
amount of people's lives who we've
ruined for for these non-violent
victimless crimes
so the the progressive prosecutors kind
of use that popular energy to rise up
and then they went okay but not only are
we going to do that yeah we're also
going to go really easy on violent
criminals we're also going to
decriminalize not just shoplifting but
strong armed robbery carjacking and all
of this because we don't want to throw
throw away the book for anyone except
when someone's uh exercising
self-defense then they become reaganite
drug warrior prosecutors who want to
throw the book at you who want to like
throw you know 30 years in jail for so
it creates controlled demolitions yes it
creates this thing that is
obviously just going to destroy
civilization you can't have a society
where you legalize property crimes and
violent crimes asset de facto legalize
them
and then punish people for defending
themselves they're they are they are
punishing the good the let me live my
life happily and leave me alone and
exonerating allowing commuting
protecting the bad quite literally it's
like
letting the demons loose
and
it it's it's an inversion of what the
system is and what's protecting you and
my only point there is that basically
that like the um the conservative
prosecutors gave them this lane from 40
years of insane aggressive prosecutions
of people for like drug possession
charges so then they could run against
that and then be like isn't that so
horrible and then they give us this
insanity what we need is libertarian
prosecutors basically is that yes let's
not throw people in jail for drug
possession or gun possession but also if
you defend your life or your property
then that we should always come down on
the side of that person and against the
criminal it should be like this i'm
imagining there's like a d.a
and uh there's like a courtroom and some
guy mugged some other guy and so here
they both are one dudes on trial for the
crime one dude's you know the victim and
then the judge is just like
okay so you know we've heard all the
evidence it really does sound like you
mugged this guy then he looks over the
victim and says do you have a gun and he
goes uh no i don't he was okay so
restitution will be we're gonna give you
a gun it's cheaper to give you a gun
than put this guy in jail we're gonna
tell this guy
don't commit crimes because the next
time dude's going to be armed and so
will everyone else i'm kidding by the
way but the idea is like
if people were armed
good good law-abiding citizens who are
armed west virginia i've never had a
problem with them i see i saw a guy
walking on the street with a crossbow
once and i'm like how's it going do you
support uh prosecuting violent crime oh
yeah of course what about
cr people that command people to do
violence
so i'm sorry so oh so will someone
reorder this priest things like that and
then someone goes and knocks that one's
down yeah this is why people who command
other people to do violence ought to be
prosecuted too that's why george w bush
and barack obama should all be in a cell
somewhere for the uh the wars that they
cut hey did you guys know that obama and
trump two and biden too
because it's like i want to pardon all
it's like what you mean we put this
obama murdered a kid oh yeah several
yeah several but no nobody like an
american an american citizen
right but but we don't even need to say
that we can just say did you know that
barack obama murdered a kid yeah like
murdered an american kid people are
going to be like what like an american
it wasn't murder because it was legal no
no it wasn't no literally trying to let
some bombing
no not even that it was a civilian
restaurant in a country we weren't at
war with
he blew up civilians an american citizen
and we weren't at war with yemen it was
the definition of like it wasn't it
wasn't even a war crime because we're
not at war it was just literally obama
murdering somebody yeah but and by the
way that's when obama was uh uh drone
bombing yemen up to 2009 2010 when we
were on uh the site we were drone
bombing to supposedly kill al qaeda but
then he switched and okay we continued
the bombing campaign to this day on the
side of al qaeda because now we're
against the houthis because we had to
kind of win over favor with the saudis
again so we kept that war going this
entire time and switched sides and we
are still to this day currently fighting
on the side of al qaeda so mix war
crimes with treason with genocide yeah
and that's what you've got in yemen
right now like donald trump was like why
do we have troops over there and donald
trump was trying to get our troops out
donald trump was lied to by uh uh who i
can't remember who lied to him about
syria told them that we yeah they
bragged about it they were worried about
that we they forced to keep our troops
in we had the abraham accords we had
trump uh negotiating with north korea we
had trump basically being like i don't
know why we're involved in about this
stuff this is costing us money for no
reason but yeah but no excuses for him
man because
he first of all he wrote up like first
off he got tricked into surging in
afghanistan before he finally agreed to
end it and then he agrees to end it on a
timeline that will be on the next guy's
administration i i guess he assumed he
was getting reelected but what he took
that risk by the way he had colonel
douglas mcgregor come in to the defense
department in the lame duck session
after he lost the election but before he
was out and he uh he rode up the order
to remove all troops from syria and
afghanistan and trump signed it and then
the next day trump took it back because
someone got in the room with them and
convinced him not to do it and he did
this over and over and over again so
fine it is true that they all misled him
and lied to him but like no excuses for
the commander-in-chief and president he
had four years in there of being the
commander-in-chief the genocide in yemen
continued every single day of his
administration by the way uh 1833
go there there's a war powers resolution
coming up this is the big project of the
libertarian party right now to try to
get you to go call your congressman
there's a bill in the congress uh in the
house and the senate to try to bring an
end to this jennifer i got it i gotta
push back a little bit just because
i think in terms of war trump was the
best president of my lifetime why
because he was getting our troops out he
didn't start any new ones he okay he
didn't start any new ones he definitely
uh
gave david who gave it his best try when
he uh murdered selem salamani and could
have gotten us into the worst war in the
last 20 years i didn't say it was thank
god i didn't say that was good i who was
better
every other president in my life started
several wars
and so i understand like bro okay but it
started listen i like that talking point
i like that the talking point is he
didn't start a new war rather than it
being like he was so great because he
was so aggressive you know like he was
such a war hawk like it would have been
with previous republicans but i mean
okay he didn't start any new wars that
is technically true again he flirted
around and flirted in venezuela but
you know
the the number of civilian casualties
actually went up in his uh you know he
didn't end any of the wars he continued
all of them uh well he okay i give him
all the credit in the world he authored
the deal that ultimately ended the war
in afghanistan and by the way even
though he botched the execution i gave
biden credit too for ending that fine
but donald trump was the
commander-in-chief for four years on the
promise that he was going to end these
wars no excuse making for that he kept
them all going for all four years
i think the difference in our
perspectives is because i agree with you
but my thing is like i have to
be positive on people who are making
progress
so that we can continue to encourage the
the election of people who will follow
further and further in that direction of
but then i'll say if we want to make
progress but but he didn't really make
progress and is what i'm saying if more
people are being killed if more
what is that so that's a p what deal
what what piece did he strike with who
so when you have planes that are
traveling over israel right when you
have countries like what is it saudi
arabia among other arabic nations that
are now allowing an inter-country
commerce it's just a step in the right
direction no there was no war between
saudi arabia and israel there was no war
between the union
so basically what he did was in these in
these peace deals is he basically bought
off these other muslim countries to be
friends with israel when they had vowed
well when they had vowed to not be
friends with israel over their treatment
of the palestinian people and so we
bribed them with u.s taxpayer dollars to
look the other way and let israel do
what they want to do to the palestinian
people in order to not like be enemies
with them so if that's a peace deal fine
but if i'm talking about the actual wars
the war in in yemen the war in uh in
somalia the wars in all of these
countries like no he didn't end them so
that's the type of peace deal i'd be
looking for so i agree with you i want
to see progress but i think the way to
get progress is to say like no that's
not good enough we're actually expecting
when we when you run on saying we're
going to end the wars that means end the
freaking wars like end them all this is
insane we're draining we're bankrupting
our country to be the empire of the
world and for what what do we even get
out of it what have we got okay in the
last 20 years in iraq afghanistan libya
syria somalia pakistan yemen like all
these campaigns what have we gotten from
petrodollar yeah opium and lithium no no
no no no no no no no no no it's the
petrodone right it's that we don't have
to do anything to buy oil literally
nothing
the funny thing about that is that it's
like even that
how does that benefit the american
people i mean what it benefits it
benefits the federal reserve right like
they can print all the money they want
and there's still something that's kind
of backing up its currency but how is
that actually benefiting regular people
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you